foreign
[Music]
we're doing it
good morning everyone
oh
welcome to the writing Club
do I still not have sound
still don't have sound
[Music]
that's great for some reason
my computer just isn't playing sound
so I can't hear
anything
which is super ideal
when you're um
doing an interactive live stream that's
probably the most ideal is when you
don't have sound
that's you that's usually my favorite
part of having like a super nice
computer that's never supposed to fail
uh is when it does that's my favorite
part
I don't know it sometimes doesn't it
sometimes doesn't I have no idea
so
um
great
cool
I don't know it's been doing this all
morning though so I'm super grateful
um
but you know what I'm most grateful that
y'all show up anyway
and as long as y'all can hear me
then we all gravy shouty oh my
oh Bob said
oh Bob said y'all can hear me oh well
that works
well thank you Mary appreciate that
cool
oh oh I have sound oh great thank you
Bobby okay cool
as long as y'all can hear me because I
can't hear sh right now
I don't I don't know why
I mean like
so I guess I just won't do sound effects
because I don't know what's working and
what's not
foreign
but I don't want to start this off on a
negative foot so let's let's reset
let's get back to it
the purpose of being here is gratitude
set that intention moving forward
and
away we go
so yes Guinness is extra fluffy today
what's so funny
I turned 35 yesterday
and I literally woke up
with like my neck hurting
like the right side of my neck has been
like tight and it like hurts to turn it
right when I woke up on my 35th birthday
and then it's been hurting ever since so
that's a good sign for the future right
I think that's
um I guess this is
this is when those things start when you
just wake up and you have no idea why so
that's good
oh yeah as Bob said I'm older now so
maybe it's my hearing that's going
could be a very valid point there Bob
that's hilarious
hilarious
I know I can't figure out technology
but Guinness is here y'all are so
excited about getting ass ain't that fun
excuse me
he's here he's here
all right
this sound is really annoying me and it
shouldn't be but
I
I guess you're just one of those things
where you're like
you pay for it to work so it should work
tight deal
we gotta Let It Go
um cool
well thank you all so much for coming
out this was a very professional intro
welcome to the right 10 Club everyone
everything is great hope you all are
doing well
um
peeps watching on YouTube keeps watching
our Facebook group
welcome one and all my friends
as we getting into it here shouty we
about to write a joke live on the air
so
yeah I did find that funny though that
the first
the first day of my birthday
is when um
oh I just saw Bobby posted happy
birthday in my in the Facebook group
yesterday wow thank you I just noticed
that
that's just funny the first thing that
happens at 35 is I wake up in my neck
that's hilarious
all right
so we are about to
jump in and we are about
to do a live joke writing exercise
so here we go
stretch everyone get ready
this is gonna be a good one
um
this one's for all the OG right Tenors
uh who have seen The Good The Bad and
The Crying of this show
this is going to be one of the good ones
we're gonna write a joke live
and then we're all gonna be like yay
we did it we wrote a joke live
and it's going to be amazing
and we're all gonna feel good because we
came together as a comedy community
and created a new joke out of thin air
in just 10 minutes
and then we'll read them live on the air
and then we'll share feedback and it'll
be a positive Fellowship of funny a
fellowship of funny that's fun
and it all starts with me sitting back
up in my chair
so that's a good place to start
so maybe in three two
one
boom
all right there we go oh my heavens
all right
wait till you throw out your back trying
to take a poop hilarious
that's hilarious who said that
in the Facebook group
Bobby said my warranty is running out
hilarious
oh Ryan thank you Ryan Ryan said happy
birthday
this is a good one to join Ryan the day
after my birthday where I'm feeling
all the energy here at 10 A.M
um
hilarious oh Bobby said throw out your
back taking a poop man I'm so excited
I did get what I wanted for my birthday
I got some great gifts and great quality
family time
so it was all gravy baby
all right so now that we have weeded out
all the non-committed right Tenors with
a little weird rant oh my gosh yo
that is ridiculous I cannot believe
my neck
this is unbelievable
unbelievable
That's What Guinness is thinking
ah
all right so let's get into it
let's get into the live joke riding
it's gonna feel better after
all right here we go
all right all right all right all right
here we go here we go we're doing it
we're doing it this time we're doing it
here we go
we're doing it we're doing it
everything's good
maybe if I do like 10 push-ups
there we go now we're back
all right
all right so let's get into it
we're doing it
Adrian goes are we doing it we didn't do
it
hilarious
all right we're doing it we got the
endorphins going with a little push-up
action we're doing it so so let me see
what this camera
setup looking like
and what we'll do
um
we'll play the intro
the sound
why is there no sound
I I done that I've done that
but what's weird is that you have sound
so me yelling why is there no sound
feels like
I'm having some sort of mental breakdown
which I am but not about the sound
um
so here's what we'll do
we'll play the intro
welcome
to the right tank Club
goody
goody word of the day is
we are the right 10 Club
all right
we're here baby
we are here
all right
so here we go
oh people ask about the pin sponsor
today
the pin today
is from uniball
the uniball 207 Plus
I like these pens these are good pins
they write well they're nice and smooth
it's just good clean fun these uniball
pins you know it'd be dope is if
we had pen sponsors
that uh
paid for the show
that would be cool
um
that would be fun
but with a commercial like that how
could no pen want to not be a sponsor of
the show
yeah that's fun
it's a good it's a good fun pin it's
lightweight
um has like a plastic body
they write just so smooth though
um it's a nice Stern grip
it's a nice Stern grip there on that
uniball 207 Plus
it's just good clean fun this is the red
Edition
I got it in a three pack of black blue
and red
you can get these at your local
pen store I think I got these at Target
Maybe
but
it's definitely worth it and we will see
uh how it writes a joke so
the word of the day my friends
is simple
the the date is 125 23.
and let's keep it simple today now all
right let's let's lower the bar
my brain is on four right now out of 400
it feels like
I I am amazed at my neck though I think
that's my favorite part is I woke up
yesterday welcome to 35 your neck hurts
for no reason and now it still does
maybe it's all this negativity that we
need to get over
huh
Target had g2s
um g2s are good I liked YouTube I got
like a package you twos
that um
yeah
that were in like different colors like
green and stuff it was really cool
but also have the uniball this is the
307 the signo 307 so this is a good one
too I like this one but you see they're
both red I like to write with different
colors and stuff just uh
just to mix it up
um yeah we'll go with the 207 plus today
ah I think oh Jessica said negativity
that's hilarious
it's true
so
we have 10 minutes on the clock the word
of the day is simple
I don't know what's gonna happen
but here we go
10 minutes on the clock
let's get to it
all right so with the word simple we'll
start simple
what comes to mind when you think of
simple
simple syrup that's where we'll start
with sugar
simple syrup keep it simple as a phrase
you know you want to just brainstorm
different things
around
um what comes to mind when you think of
simple simple also means
you know it could also mean easy
uh fast
simple instructions
so if they're also common phrases like I
said like keep it simple
is one
simple tin
harsh said simp yes indeed simp
um
I mean you know Simply the Best you know
that's not the word simple but it's
something that simple makes you think of
because right now we are just uh
brainstorming there's no wrong there's
no right it's literally just getting
ideas out onto the page as Jerry said
there simple-minded that's a good one
I like that one
simple instructions keep it simple
Simply the Best
uh um
samp simple
makes me think of sample as well
simple kind of man isn't that a um
Leonard Skynyrd song
simple kind of man maybe
simple
I think so
which is in Leonard Skynyrd
music
um band
all right anything else we can think of
we kind of just get ideas out at the
beginning
and just kind of uh
get a bunch of thoughts out and then
we'll go back in kind of the second half
and formula it
boring
yeah that's a good one too
simple's another kind of it's like it's
boring it's simple it's easy
mundane
[Music]
Simple Simon
Jessica said instead of calling people
with loose morals easy or fast we call
them simple
um
Simple Simon Simon Says
simple what could be simple if we're
talking about something simple like Ikea
so maybe simple instructions
um
simple instructions
cool
so as I look through what we've
brainstormed a little bit here
because we're thinking of things to
think of when you think of simple
keep it simple simpleton
but also part of it is like okay then
how can we personalize these examples so
for me maybe
you know math
the opposite is a good brainstorming
exercise as well
simple mathematics
yep so that's another good way because
you kind of stretch your brain in
different directions we kind of did hit
a wall and thinking of what are things
we think of with simple all right what
is the opposite of that so that's a good
point there
Adrian which would be like hard
difficult
complex
um
roadblock
writer's block
sug to
write jokes I follow this
simple
formula
to write jokes I follow this simple
go to open mic
deal others
jokes now of course we would never do
that of course the cardinal sin of
Comedy is stealing material
but this is a joke not a great one
um yeah I'd like to personalize it so I
think something about like
simple for me
simple childhood
so it could be something like
simple
childhood so a way to
write a joke is to remix
the uh Assumption of a word so
how what can word be re like the word
simple
I had a simple childhood
so how could that be so a simple May
mean it was easy
privileged
stable
how is simple interpreted
foreign
amicable the divorce was amicable
growing up I had a simple childhood
You Can't Always Get What You Want
so you see it's starting to kind of work
on
reversing the Assumption of I had a
great childhood
You Can't Always Get What You Want
bullies
all right two and a half minutes here's
we are landing the plane
I'm going up had a simple childhood
or it could be the good old days
before technology
or social media
life was simple
for Tech before social media life was
simple or instead of Life maybe dating
before social media dating was simple
don't go
blind date
simple-minded Simply the Best simp
dating was simple
dating apps Tinder what was simple about
it
or not before technology
Maybe
technology
makes dating
[Music]
simple
so what's something about dating
I'm all over the place today man but we
have 38 seconds to get something
together here maybe we go back here
growing up I had a simple childhood
Amish
growing up life was simple before social
media life was simple
uh
foreign
oh Guinness was worried did you see that
Guinness Guinness got worried hey buddy
hey buddy
thank you oh my neck
oh Guinness was worried
that's so nice
oh Guinness hey bud
oh thank you
thank you
what's up
hey bud
the Guinness was worried I'm so glad
it's all right I think we're all right
[Music]
oh yeah Jessica said something about
dating simple and stalking yeah I just
I don't know
I don't know man
I didn't really come up with anything
today and that's fine
we came up with this live stream that's
good enough
um
yeah you know part of
writing jokes as you're right 20 and
keep one
so for this 10 minute writing exercise
it's just kind of brainstorming and
seeing what we can come up with
um
yeah I didn't really cope with anything
today growing up had a simple childhood
simple
I don't know
um
the simple truth is oh yeah it's always
a complicated lie oh yeah that's good
Neil yeah simple truth that's a good one
nice
well yeah
very nice so yeah that's the joke
writing exercise the word of the day is
simple so if you have a joke using that
word feel free to put it in the live
stream
and I'll read it live on the air but um
yeah
Jerry said it's not simple to write
jokes
maybe it's um
maybe it's a writing jokes is simple
it's the punch line that's difficult
something like that
yeah cool
well there you go
oh
cool
um cool
[Music]
nice
oh my gosh Evelyn just donated to my
birthday fund thank you Evelyn
how exciting
thank you
that's so nice
um
yay ah
thank you Evelyn
oh Adrian said um writing jokes is
simple writing funny jokes is where I
dropped the ball
that's nice yeah yeah
all right
so let's read some of your jokes here my
friends
[Music]
thank you Evelyn and I saw Joan donated
to the birthday fund as well thank you
you know what's ridiculous is
I posted on social media yesterday that
it was my birthday and I was raising
money for my dog's teeth fund
and my wife took that personally
and she thought our dog is insecure
about his teeth and I was exploiting it
on social media
right
yep
yep yep yep yep yep
marriage is so simple oh that could be
the setup marriage is simple do what
you're told
marriage is simple
comes with instructions
all right
which could do your jokes
what do y'all think
my neck 35.
by golly
I appreciate y'all hanging out goodness
we're at 28 people and I am just on here
just rambling
but we're about to read your jokes let's
get into it
when y'all do post your jokes on the
live chat do
um
do
when you post them in the live chat
this is this is one of the
most discombobulated
live streams we've done in a while
for sure
this one's
a bit all over the place this one is not
so simple
you know doing
a live stream every week is not so
simple doing two live streams a week per
week is not so simple
this is not so simple
every week how can we do this
I don't know if I can keep doing it
every week
I don't know
how can we make it work for everyone
I don't want to let anyone down
but
I don't know
every week
I don't know maybe if like Guinness
could host it
how could it work I don't know every
week
I don't know
what do y'all think
what's fair
I've been doing this a long time
how can we
make it work don't give us up
I don't know it's tough to do it
every week
but this seems to be working
I think this is working
what do y'all think
how about this we could do this every
week
that works
does it show up here every week and I'll
just have a video of my chair
that works and then it's just like a
guest
someone sent Joe some coffee stat
hilarious
ah all right we're back
that was pretty fun right
um
I appreciate Mary
saying do what's best for you and
everyone else is like hey this is fun
and free and easy let's do it
I don't know
but I do know we're here and now
so we'll um
keep it going here
I remember we did other co-hosts in the
past like during the pandemic when we
were doing it every day
and the people with co-host and be like
oh my gosh how do you do this
they'd be like how do you do this every
week
I did it every day actually
one second
oh I need to read yours I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I'm here oh my gosh my bad I was just
um
I'm about to release
a YouTube video
about
um how Nate bargatzi became
um
Jimmy Fallon's favorite comedian and
they just sent me some thumbnails
oh no
why can't I see them
so I was looking at them
uh which I'll share with you because
you're hanging out live here and that's
why you're here right
you're here
oh let's not go there one second
there they are looky there
so there's a they sent me two
which one do you all like
which one do you all like better
name or no name
yeah Nate was on Fallon last night
left 100 percent
name name name
no name no name
name name name name name
[Music]
need a name but no name is the better
image
name
you think so
the No Name pick creeps me out but it
may get your attention
the face on the right that people will
click on
yeah when you're looking
he's looking right at you so like as
you're
scrolling through
on YouTube I feel like the face on the
right will get your attention
because he's literally like looking
right at you
let's think about YouTube thumbnails
it's crazy out here fam just the
psychology of all of it is
it's a whole other game
I like I think the I think the No Name
is attention grabbing
you know
well there we go now they're like side
by side
enter his finger about the biggest nose
hilarious
add name to the pick somehow hmm
I don't know yeah
is that you aren't in it
very true
cool
I'm glad we worked that out
yeah I think we'll try the one with no
name first
I mean the thing about YouTube is you
you post it and then they give you a
bunch of data
um and then you can work it out from
there
and we're falling on the thumbnail we'll
get more clicks
some good points being made here
hmm
yeah that's a Tuffy there
man that's a Tuffy I don't know
we'll have to post one and see
see what sticks there
but yeah if y'all are not subscribed to
my YouTube channel yet definitely do
that we're dropping some bangers over
there
I'm doing more like video essay
storytelling Style videos
um
and they super dope they are super dope
The Fluffy one
has like a hundred and thirty thousand
views
and the rest around
hundreds low thousands so
we're figuring it out we're figuring it
out
but um
I'm definitely excited about that
new channel
but
let's get into your jokes oh my gosh I
totally got 80d and derailed
but you know I like to I like to let
y'all in on the process I like and
appreciate your opinions
new no name looks like Fallon is
sneaking up behind him
I know
it's tough it's tough to know
yeah
we'll see though we shall see hopefully
that video will be ready
I was going over edits on it before this
um so hopefully we'll be ready
uh by today or tomorrow
the latest
um
but yeah
Sean Joy said it's simple hilarious
very funny I know right it's all super
simple
but I keep hearing YouTube is a skill so
I'm really
really going all in on learning the
skill of YouTube because I think we can
really create some awesome stuff
on this channel as well as we continue
to grow and evolve
um
like we did during this live stream we
really have gone up and down and all
around and y'all sat through all of it
so I appreciate that
and Guinness does as well
um
oh and Bobby said we have a tie a
three-way tie for first
nice Jessica in our Facebook group
we actually do this joke writing
exercise on our Facebook group
um
every uh
every day
Bobby will post a new word
in our Facebook group and people will
write using that word
and then uh people vote by liking them
so I just put a link to it
in the live chat to our Facebook group
that's where the voting goes down
um
but in the meantime in between time
let's let's read some of your jokes here
my friends
um
let's see here
so Morris
Morris's joke when it comes to Comedy I
keep things simple as a one-man
operation
I don't qualify for a set IRA
I'm not sure what a sep
Ira is
separa
I mean I know what an IRA is but a SEP
IRA maybe I'm not that old yet but I
should know I mean ra retirement's
important
but thank you for sharing Morris
uh Bob I left a simple sample of myself
with my girlfriend now it's paid
dividends we call it little Bobby oh
my Heavens I'll see you Bob
uh a Joan
my tastes are simple it's my bank
account it's complicated
very funny
that's a good one nicely done there Joan
uh Jerry
my kids teacher said the new math was
easier yet my old math lets me figure
out simple division problems faster than
my kids
my kids teacher said the new math was
easier yet my old math lets me figure
out simple division problems faster than
my kids
yeah I hear that parents trying to help
their kids with their homework it's
becoming more and more difficult
yeah yeah nice use of simple there
Jerry
Aaron despiva I have a simple weight
loss problem I go to the grocery store
and see the prices
oh simple weight loss program
that's good
yeah yeah
ah
simple weight loss program very funny
there Aaron
[Music]
um
Adrian said finding true love is simple
be attractive be rich or be willing to
lower our expectations I've introduce
you to my body pillow life mate Kiko oh
all right
Pete
heart surgery becomes simple after doing
it hundreds of times in fact I'm so good
that I don't even know if the nose
lights up anymore oh operation joke nice
Sandy
as a Student Success coach I advise
young women on the simplest way to
finance their college education find a
sugar daddy all right
yes Queen yes
Ben Webb I'm a mental health expert with
five simple steps you too can be farther
away from people
mental health expert how would you
diagnose this live stream hmm
all right next joke
1sp comedy said as a kid I said good
morning to my 40 Butlers life was simple
back then nice
Ryan Wingfield I'm pretty sure the
simple life was referring to Paris
Hilton's IQ oh shots fired that's a
clever one though she had a show called
the simple life right
big that's a clever one there Ryan
super topical hmm
I'm not sure who's this one is
I figured out how to abstain from sex it
was simple I got married again all right
nice nice misdirect
Mary Elizabeth
people around town called the town over
simple Valley
what can one expect when cow patty Bingo
is your school's largest fundraiser
hilarious
cow patty bingo
we got d
uh how life was simple before the
invention of social media now I need
report
to scrolling every few minutes big facts
I guess Jessica had one about dating
Jessica
dating was simple instead of stalking
their social media to see who their exes
were we would just go to the doctor to
see what STDs they gave us very funny
uh Neil Prettyman
my girlfriend enjoys the simple things
in life
a beautiful sunrise couple of hot
morning coffee and dreaming that one day
I won't wake up
all right a power of Threes there
Bobby
people say I should be livid when
another comic steals my material the
simple truth is I'm just shocked anyone
was paying attention to me in the first
place all right
nice yes we love attention
for sure
[Music]
Brian Guilfoyle I knew a painter years
ago but he wasn't the smartest guy to be
honest I met him recently though and
he's a PhD now I guess he's the artist
formerly known as simple
oh that's nice and silly there Brian
Mary Baker I'm a simple kind of woman
like a squirrel I work hard play harder
and question everything
and my question everything attitude only
draws nuts
fun fun analogy there
um Evelyn
my friend told me the guy I was dating
was simple after I broke up with him
I told her he was stupid she said that's
what simple means maybe we were a better
match than I realized
my friend told me the guy I was dating
was simple after I broke up with him I
told
my my friend
told me the guy I was dating was simple
after I broke up with him I told her he
was stupid she said that's what simple
means maybe we were a better match than
ever
oh my gosh that's hilarious I'm so glad
I talked through that I was all over the
place for a second that's hilarious
uh
[Music]
um
next joke next joke Scott Shanahan
I like to pause now and then to enjoy
life's Simple Pleasures that's probably
why I'm getting fired
[Music]
um
oh I'm seeing all these words
I had already forgotten when I had a
mental breakdown in the middle of this
we're like can I even do this and people
are like take time off
you deserve it
thank you
I know I don't know
oh nice Noah said
how can I get more involved with what
you're doing at hot breath
I've been doing comedy for four months
now did my first page show
congratulations
[Applause]
yeah yeah I mean just sharing the live
streams we do and joining our Facebook
group is a good way to connect with
other members of the hopper at the verse
as well
uh congrats fam on getting on stage and
your first paid gig that's big moves
there
Aaron Arledge
I told my son it's simple to make it to
the big leagues where fans will love him
he just needs to practice yelling cold
beer get your cold
nice misdirect around big leagues there
nicely done there Aaron
Joyce
my taste my taste in men is simple they
need to have blue eyes a nice butt and
erectile dysfunction
a little power of Threes there
oh thank you Scott yes Jessica asked
about something more than one joke yes
you can
um but I just read the one
I just read the one
um so we have time to get to other
people's
um
as we are here
nice I think I got to all the jokes
though
and who's winning who won
it's simple to see
that Ben Webb won oh snap our mental our
resident mental health expert won
um coincidence
ah
congratulations Ben
man this is a roller coaster all around
and about wasn't it but we made it
and I appreciate you all so much and I
appreciate your feedback on those
thumbnails
as well
so we shall see I will let y'all know
when that nape video goes live I'll post
it in the Facebook group which I could
please share it
we gotta blow those things up man
we gotta blow that channel up
for sure
but congratulations to Ben holy cow
that is awesome
oh and look everyone's saying congrats
been
yeah hey man thank you all so much for
hanging out goodness gracious it means
the world that y'all come and hang out
and put up with my dramaizations
uh but I appreciate y'all so much
but I think that is it
we went a little over I don't know why
we went over today it couldn't be any
ramblings of any sorts
but y'all are awesome I love this
community I appreciate y'all so much
um we'll probably be back next week
we'll definitely be doing our Tuesday
live stream
um
what does y'all have seen I haven't
posted a podcast in a little while
either since the first week of the year
so I don't
we're figuring it out here
but we're in we're in like a a
transition transitional stage right now
so we're about to hit the ground running
though
but I appreciate y'all so much
I love y'all and as we say here angels
on y'all angels on y'all
Angel's on y'all right Tenors y'all have
a good day say bye Guinness
I love y'all we'll see y'all next
Tuesday
have a good day
bye